>> THAT'S THE KEY QUESTION.
>> WHY DID HE HAVE THEM, TAKE
THEM?
STILL DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER TO
THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> LET'S BRING IN FORMER FBI
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE
AND CNN CONTRIBUTOR FORMER NIXON
WHITE HOUSE COUNCIL JOHN DEAN.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
I WANT TO HOLD UP THE FRONT PAGE
OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES," PEOPLE
MIGHT BE ASKING WHAT'S THE BIG
DEAL WITH THESE DOCUMENTS, WHY
ARE WE MAKING SUCH A FUSS OF
TRUMP HAVING THESE DOCUMENTS AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
U.S. FEARED TRUMP FILE PUTS
SPIES AT RISK.
THAT'S THE FEAR THERE.
THE FEAR IS OUR U.S. SPIES MAY
HAVE BEEN PUT AT RISK IN ALL OF
THIS.
ANDREW, YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> JIM, IT'S JUST ABSOLUTELY
STUNNING.
THIS SORT OF INFORMATION IS THE
LIFE BREAD OF OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY APPARATUS.
THE COLLECTION OF SOURCE
INFORMATION, THE COLLECTION OF
SIGNALS INTELLIGENCE WHICH IS
OVER YEARS THE COMMUNICATIONS OF
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS AND FOREIGN
TERRORIST ENTITIES, ALL KINDS OF
THINGS.
FISA COVERAGE, OUR OWN CORPORATE
AUTHORIZED INTERCEPTIONS OF
INTELLIGENCE, AND, OF COURSE,
HUMAN INTELLIGENCE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES ARE
LITERALLY ON THE LINE EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
IF THEIR EFFORTS TO ASSIST THE
UNITED STATES ARE UNCOVERED,
THEY COULD DIE.
AND TO THINK --
>> SOMEBODY COULD GET KILLED AS
A RESULT OF THIS INFORMATION
BEING OUT THERE.
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
AND TO THINK THAT THE MAN WHO
USED TO BE -- SWORE AN OATH TO
ENSURE THAT THE LAWS ARE
FAITHFULLY EXECUTED.
THE GUY WHO WAS FORMERLY
RESPONSE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
SECURITY OF THIS NATION HAS THAT
STUFF SITTING IN HIS BASEMENT
MIXED IN WITH PHOTOS AND LETTERS
IT'S STUNNING AND WILDLY
DANGEROUS.
>> JOHN DEAN, 184 CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, TOTALING 700 PAGES,
THESE ARE THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS THAT THE FBI FOUND.
THIS IS THE STUFF THAT TRUMP
GAVE THEM.
WHAT STANDS OUT TO YOU?
>> WELL, I THINK PROBABLY THE
MOST IMPRESSIVE THING IS THE
CARELESSNESS WITH WHICH TRUMP
HANDLED THIS.
I REMEMBER MY BRIEFING WHEN I
GOT MY TOP SECRET CLEARANCE AND
I ACTUALLY WAS ABOVE TOP SECRET.
AND TWO AGENTS CAME OVER FROM
THE CIA AND HAD MY SECRETARY
THERE, AND WE HAD ABOUT A 35, 40
MINUTE CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW TO
DEAL WITH THESE DOCUMENTS, WHAT
WERE THE CONSEQUENCES IF THEY
EVER LEAKED.
WE HAD TO HAVE A SAFE INSTALLED
IN THE OFFICE TO DEAL WITH THEM.
AND THEY IMPRESSED ME BECAUSE
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY SAID, IF
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE COMPROMISED
THAT YOU GET, SOME -- IT COULD
BE SOMEBODY'S LIFE.
AND THAT'S PRETTY DANGEROUS.
AND I'M SURE -- I CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT TRUMP WOULDN'T HAVE GOTTEN
EVEN A BETTER BRIEFING THAN I
GOT AS WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL.
SO THE CARELESSNESS TO TAKE
THESE -- ACTUALLY, WE DON'T KNOW
IF HE PACKED THEM UP OR ORDERED
THEM PACKED UP, WE DON'T HAVE
THOSE DETAILS YET.
BUT WE KNOW HE DID LEARN THEY
WERE AT MAR-A-LAGO, AND HE
CALLED THEM HIS DOCUMENTS.
HE WANTED TO KEEP THEM.
HE WAS TOLD THEY WEREN'T HIS BUT
YET HE CONTINUED TO OBSTRUCT, IF
YOU WILL, AND I THINK THAT HE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO PAY THE PIPER
ON THIS ONE.
>> ANDREW, I WANT TO ZOOM IN ON
THIS -- I GUESS THIS PHRASE NO
FOREIGN, THIS DESIGNATION, NO
FOREIGN.
AGAIN THAT MEANS NO RELEASE TO
FOREIGN NATIONALS.
IT'S EYE CATCHING BECAUSE
SEVERAL FOREIGN NATIONALS HAVE
BEEN ARRESTED AT MAR-A-LAGO IN
YEARS FROM TIME TO TIME AND A
NEW REPORT FROM THE PITTSBURGH
POST GAZETTE SAYS AN
INVESTIGATION IS UNDER WAY OF A
UKRAINIAN IMMIGRANT WHO USED A
FAKE ID TO RUB ELBOWS WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP LAST YEAR THERE
WHILE THESE DOCUMENTS WERE
THERE.
SO I GUESS YOU WOULD BE
COMMITTING MALPRACTICE IF YOU
DID NOT HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT
THIS.
>> I SPENT MANY YEARS CONDUCTING
AND OVERSEEING
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATIONS.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT MAR-A-LAGO
IS A SPY'S DREAM.
IT'S A SOFT TARGET.
IT'S OPEN TO THE PUBLIC.
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF WAYS IN FOR
A TRAINED, DETERMINED
INTELLIGENCE OFFICER.
THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF WAYS IN
THERE.
AND YOU KNOW THAT IF YOU GET IN,
YOU'VE GOT A PERSON WHO HAD
ACCESS TO THE GOVERNMENT'S MOST
SENSITIVE SECRETS, AND WHO ALSO
HAS SHOWN A TRACK RECORD OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS OF
HANDLING THOSE SECRETS
IRRESPONSIBLY, SHARING WITH
PEOPLE HE SHOULDN'T HAVE AND
OBVIOUSLY STORING STUFF IN AN
UNAUTHORIZED FASHION ON THE
PREMISES.
SO IT'S ABSOLUTELY A SPY'S DREAM
TO TARGET TO TRY TO GET INTO
MAR-A-LAGO AND GET A LOOK AROUND
AT WHATEVER YOU MIGHT FIND.
>> AND JOHN, THE AFFIDAVIT LAYS
OUT FOUR OBJECTIVES OF THIS
PROBE, ONE IS TO QUOTE IDENTIFY
ANY PERSON OR PERSONS WHO MAY
HAVE REMOVED OR RETAINED
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION WITHOUT
AUTHORIZATION, AND/OR IN AN
UNAUTHORIZED SPACE, THAT'S ONE
OF THE KEY MYSTERIES HERE.
HOW MANY HANDS DID THESE PASS
THROUGH I SUPPOSE IS ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS ON THE WAY TO
MAR-A-LAGO.
AND IF TRUMP DIDN'T PACK OR
TRANSPORT THESE DOCUMENTS
HIMSELF, DOES THAT MATTER IN
TERMS OF HIS LEGAL DEFENSE?
>> WELL, I THINK HE'S ALREADY
CLAIMED THAT THE MOVERS DID
THIS.
AND THEY PACKED THEM UP AND GSA,
THE PEOPLE WHO DID ACTUALLY DO
SOME TRANSPORTING SAY THEY DID
NOT PACK THE BOXES.
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT
PHASE OF IT.
SO, YOU KNOW, THERE WILL BE A
LOT OF FINGER POINTING GOING
AROUND.
BUT I THINK THE BASIC ISSUE IS,
YOU KNOW, HE HAS A REPUTATION
FOR THIS KIND OF MISHANDLING.
WHEN YOU READ THE AFFIDAVIT,
YOU'RE STRUCK BY THE DEPTH OF
RESEARCH AND INVESTIGATION
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN DONE.
THIS IS A PRETTY MATURE
INVESTIGATION, IN MY EYES.
AND I THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GET ANSWERS SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER.
I WOULD HOPE THIS YEAR.
ON WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO DEAL
WITH THIS.
BECAUSE IT IS NOW SO GLARING
THAT IT AFFECTS ALL THE HANDLING
CURRENTLY OF NATIONAL SECURITY
INFORMATION.
AND THIS CAN BE A TEACHING
MOMENT WHERE SOMEBODY, LIKE A
DONALD TRUMP WHO HAS VERY LITTLE
RESPECT FOR THE RULE OF LAW IS
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE HIM NOT BEING
AND WITH THIS BLATANT
MISBEHAVIOR AND ABUSE OF HIS
POWERS.
>> ANDREW, TRUMP AND HIS ALLIES
ARE TRYING TO DISCREDIT THE
AFFIDAVIT, WE'VE SEEN IT ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, CONSERVATIVE
SOCIAL MEDIA, ADDING THE
REDACTIONS ARE HIDING SOME SORT
OF SHAM POLITICAL ANGLE, SOME
CONSPIRACY.
HELP US SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT.
IS THIS ANYTHING UNDER THAN AN
UNPRECEDENTED TRANSPARENCY IN AN
ONGOING SENSITIVE INVESTIGATION.
THERE ARE SOME SAYING THE FEDS
GAVE AWAY TOO MUCH.
>> ONGOING INVESTIGATION,
ONGOING COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN AFFIDAVIT
FOR A SEARCH WARRANT, NO ONE IS
CHARGED YET.
SEARCH WARRANT AFFIDAVITS ARE
NEVER UNSEALED UNTIL SOMEBODY
HAS BEEN CHARGED AND THEN THE
WARRANT IN ITS FULL CONTENT IS
PROVIDED TO THE PERSON CHARGED
SO THEY CAN USE IT ESSENTIALLY
IN THEIR DEFENSE, THEY CAN
ATTACK THE WARRANT, THE PROCESS,
ALL THOSE THINGS THE DEFENDANT
CAN DO.
WE DON'T HAVE A DEFENDANT YET.
THE IDEA THE DEPARTMENT HAD TO
GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS, WAS I'M
SURE CHILLING FOR THE
PROSECUTORS INVOLVED BUT CLEARLY
THIS IS AN UNPRECEDENTED
SITUATION.
YOU HAVE A FORMER PRESIDENT
HERE, THE DEPARTMENT UNDER
ATTACK FROM THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, HIS SUPPORTERS, WITH
ALL THESE BASELESS LIES AND
MISINFORMATION ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
I THINK THE JUDGE WANTED TO BE
AS TRANSPARENT AS THEY COULD.
I THINK THE DEPARTMENT DID A
GOOD JOB, THEY LEFT A LOT OF
MEAT ON THE BONE.
THE FACTS THAT WOULD NOT
COMPROMISE THE INVES